وقد كشفت وسائل الاعلام الامريكيه ان
الجزيره تشهد ما وصفته بتعزيز منشات صينيه
للتجسس على الولايات المتحده وقد اشعلت
القضيه حربا كلاميه بين اداره الرئيس جو
بايدن وبعض الجمهوريين ما طبيعه السجالات
بين الجمهوريين والديمقراطيين حول مساله
المنشات الصينيه في كوبا هناك اتهام من
بعض الجمهوريين لاداره بعيدا بالضعف وعدم
القدره على
مواجهه الصين ولذا تتمكن الصين وخصوم
الولايات المتحده من الاقتراب على بعد 90
ميلا كما اوردت تلك التقارير
واقامه منشاه تجسسيه على شواطئ الولايات
المتحده
[موسيقى]
سارجع ستستخدم هذه الورقه انتخابيا ولكننا
الان ما زلنا في الطور الاول جدا من
الانتخابات الرئاسيه ونيكي هيلي المرشحه
الرئاسيه عن الحزب الجمهوري اتهمت بايدن
بالتقاعس اتهمت اداره بايدن بانها يجب ان
تستفيق على هذا الخطر على شواطئها وعلى
حدودها
[موسيقى]
ان القلق اعتقد قد ضخم بشكل كبير لان
الحقيقه الواقع هي ان القوى العظمى تتجسس
بعضها على الاخر ولا يحتاجون بالضروره الى
قاعده على مسافه تسعين ميلا عن الساحل
الصين لديه نشاطات تجسسيه في الولايات
المتحده من زمن بعيد وكذلك امريكا لديها
تجسس في الصين هذا امر معهود ولكن هذا
يؤكد حقيقه ان في عمليه انتخابيه حاليا هل
انتهى العمل بعقيده
المتحده فيما يتعلق بطريقه تعاملها مع
امريكا اللاتينيه في الحقيقه اذا كانت
غائبه لحد كبير خلال العقدين الماضيين عن
هذه القاره كلها من راهو الان من مزايدات
في واشنطن فيما يتعلق بالصين هو في حقيقه
مشكله كل من الجمهوريين والديمقراطيين
عانوا منها باهمالهما
اللاتينيه الاستراتيجيه طويله ما بين
المنطقه
هنالك اسباب عديده ادت الى ذلك اولا هنالك
التوسع الصيني الطبيعي الصين شاءت ان
تتوسع اقتصاديا عسكريا سياسيا في مختلف
دول العالم بعض التقاعس الامريكي بالنسبه
الى امريكا التي امريكا اللاتينيه اسباب
لدى الدول في امريكا اللاتينيه التي هي
بحاجه الى تنميه الصين عندها التفوق من
حيث انها دوله هي تدير الاقتصاد ليس هنالك
الاقتصاد الحر هنالك دول مثل كوبا مثل
نيكاراغوا وخاصه مثل فنزويلا هذه دول
تتعاطف سياسيا فكريا ايديولوجيا مع الصين
وكانت في السابق تتعاطف طبعا مع الاتحاد
السوفياتي هذا امر واضح جدا من هذا
المنطلق هذه الدول تتعاطف وتتعاون
كثيرا وتفتح ابوابها للصين اكثر من دول
اخرى
اقول للصين انه لن يكون بيننا علاقات
طبيعيه اذا قاموا بذلك سننهي التعامل
ونفرض عقوبات على منتجاتهم يجب ان نبحث
هذا الامر مع كوب ايضا يجب ان تفهم الصين
بوضوح اننا سنرد سواء اكان ذلك بالعقوبات
الاقتصاديه كي يصعب عليهم انتاج الطاقه
عندما ننظر الى رسائل الجانبين في الواقع
ما يلاحظه هو انه متوافقين فهم اساسا
يتفقان على انه لابد هناك نوع من الاحتواء
للتوسع الصيني ولكن المشكله هي كيف يمكن
احتواء الصين في هذا السياق العقوبات صعبه
جدا والعقوبات عاده لا تنجح مساله
الديمقراطيات في امريكا اللاتينيه الى اي
مدى يمكن ان يكون ذلك سند
لواشنطن في مواجهه الصين النظام
الديمقراطي في دول امريكا اللاتينيه يسهل
كثيرا تعاطي الولايات المتحده واعتقد ان
على الولايات المتحده تشجيع الدول
الديمقراطيه في امريكا اللاتينيه لاعطاء
مثلا مثلا لدول اخرى للدول غير
الديمقراطيه